well eric kendricks one of the best
linebackers in the national football
league plays for the minnesota vikings
he was not bashful about challenging the
national football league took the shield
modified it to say we want answers and
said this what actual steps are you
taking to support the fight for justice
and system reform your statement said
nothing your league is built on black
athletes vega answers do nothing let the
players know what you're actually doing
and we know what silence means and look
chris
i
i i don't want to be overly cynical here
but when the nfl perceives a problem
that potentially threatens the bottom
line it's no doubt about it action it
jumps to action this is one where
by virtue of what the league experienced
three years ago with the fallout and the
anthem controversy this is the one where
the nfl is thinking
maybe in this case action doesn't help
the bottom line maybe no action might
hurt the bottom line right yeah awesome
we have to be careful what we do and
what we say because it may affect the
bottom line now we're all for taking a
stand on on social issues that help the
bottom line but if it hurts the bottom
line that's a different conversation and
uh you know look uh sorry but we got to
call it like we see it and i i fear
based upon what happened in 2017 based
upon the things joe lockhart the former
nfl spokesman had to say in the column
posted at cnn over the weekend about the
the cold shoulder that colin kaepernick
to this day still receives it's fair to
wonder is there concern that taking real
action the action necessary to be part
of the solution the things that need to
be said to people in the highest
positions of power
if we do that are we gonna have a
backlash from a percentage of our fan
base that's gonna cancel their season
tickets and not watch the games anymore
and our ratings are gonna drop and it's
gonna hurt the bottom line
how much of that is tied up in this i
don't know oh but i think it's fair to
ask the question uh what fair to ask
fair to speculate whatever it is try to
be diplomatic i'm trying to be i know i
know you are well i'll be i'll be not
diplomatic for you okay yeah i mean i
think that's the that is the bottom line
you know this is a scary subject for the
nfl you know they don't hey
white racists buy tickets and watch
games too so we don't want to offend
them and you know of course i completely
disagree with that the game is built on
african-american players they for the
most part are the stars of our sport
they they're they're making it go
so there is no sport without them and we
need to support them especially in this
time right now where yeah how can you
feel comfortable if you're an
african-american anything athlete
businessman whatever it is you know
there's just a fear that you know a lot
of us can't really relate to and i never
could relate to and thought i could
growing up in a household where we had
giants football players over the house
and i was around you know black kids
growing up but really didn't know
anything about it until well you know
okay i go to go home with a few of my
teammates at texas or you know as i've
told the story about me driving in the
car and being pulled over with a bunch
of black athletes in the car you know we
can't really relate to that you know you
and i get pulled over in a car and we
just go man i'm going to get points on
my license or i'm going to have to pay a
fine that stinks
you know a lot of my african-american
teammates and players they got pulled
over by a policeman and they were going
oh no what is this guy going to try to
do to try to get me in jail what you
know what's going to happen here and
then it's just a scary reality and i
don't think the nfl statement was strong
enough and you're right they're not
doing enough to uh on the action side as
of right now to make feel make their
employees and their players feel better
now there are plenty of things that the
nfl is doing as it relates to efforts to
reform whether it's the justice system
etc and there has been money contributed
i mean there there are yeah there are
things done by the
by the
you know giving of money and giving of
support to things players are trying to
do so we can't say the nfl is doing
nothing but you know we need things we
need to see right we need things we need
to see and tangible and we can go like
like grab onto a little bit
especially now it's not enough to say
this is what we've been doing for the
last three years
this moment cries out to all of us for
something that we can point to and say
that is a change that was specifically
motivated by the reaction to the murder
of george floyd and the movement that
has been sparked
in its way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports